pacquiao's removal from office and
arrest in 2017 was a dramatic fall from
grace that saw her go from south korea's
president to prisoner
she's been serving a 22-year sentence
for corruption but the government's
pardon will see her released on december
31st along with around three thousand
others
we have included former president park
geun-hye and former prime minister han
myung to the list to overcome
unfortunate past history and the crisis
of covet 19 realize people's unity and
provide a chance to take a new step
forward to the future
park is currently in hospital and
analysts believe that's played a part in
her imminent release
i think it's really her advancing age
and her health issues she's had both
physical and mental health issues since
the impeachment um i mean she's pretty
clearly not going to have any kind of
meaningful political role in korean life
if she's allowed to go home as a peer is
going to happen
park was once seen as political royalty
the daughter of former president park
jung-hee she served as acting first lady
after her mother was killed in 1974
in 2013
became the country's first female leader
scoring a decisive victory for her
conservative party
but she suffered a sharp drop in public
support after more than 300 people
mostly children drowned when a ferry
capsized in 2014
just two years later another political
scandal engulfed her administration
after an old friend choice and sell was
alleged to have used her influence over
the president to meddle in state affairs
hundreds of thousands of people gathered
every weekend to demand park's
resignation
there were celebrations when she was
impeached thrown out of office and later
jailed for colluding with choi to
receive billions of dollars from major
companies the scandal also landed heads
of two conglomerates in prison
what occurred in the blue house during
her reign was unacceptable
but
and there are corruption indeed but um
overall i i personally didn't feel that
she was deeply involved into these into
the entire scheme and so um she's been
jailed she's in poor health i feel like
the time is right to let her go and and
give her the
pardon me i feel upset
as a citizen i feel that it's
regrettable that such a decision was
made all of a sudden when it would undo
what was achieved through the candlelit
vigils
almost all of south korea's former
presidents have been implicated in
corruption scandals li myung-bak the
only living ex-president aside from park
is also in prison he didn't receive a
pardon alexi o'brien al jazeera